few philosophical schools or movements
have been as influential on the Western
religions as that of neoplatonism
originating in late Antiquity with
figures like platinus porphery iamblicus
and proclus it would come to play a
decisive role in the Theology and
philosophy of Christianity Judaism and
Islam in this episode we're going to
trace some of that influence and in
particular look at the different ways in
which neoplatonism has manifested itself
and been adapted to various degrees in
the intellectual and mystical thoughts
of Islam a complex topic to be sure but
one that is very significant for a
better understanding of the history of
philosophy religion and mysticism in
general
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
once again I am so honored and happy to
say that this is part of a major massive
collaboration with my friends and
colleagues here on YouTube I'm doing
this collaboration on neoplatonism
together with zevi from Seekers of unity
Justin from esoterica Angela puka from
Angela Symposium Dana trail from the
modern hermeticist and John vervaki
we're all making separate episodes
covering the relationship of
neoplatonism to different intellectual
religious and spiritual and even
scientific traditions and schools of
thought throughout history and today so
be sure to check out all the other
videos by the other people I will leave
links to those videos in the description
you'll find videos about the
relationship of near platonism to
Kabbalah and gnosticism magic and
theology uh the platonist Philosopher's
Creed and even cognitive science it's
really amazing stuff so be sure to
follow those links and check out all
those other channels neoplate is truly a
massively important topic overlooked as
it has often been in earlier
philosophical scholarship it is a
philosophical tradition that is deep and
complex enough in itself and we have
dedicated a separate episode to
exploring and trying to understand the
general ideas of near platonism which
you should definitely consult before
watching this episode it will provide
some essential background knowledge that
is needed to appreciate our discussion
here today fully but as a very short
summary neoplatonism sometimes called
late platonism is a late antique
development within the school of
platonism primarily associated with
figures like platinus it conceives of
existence as consisting of different
levels or realities hypotheses in Greek
beginning with the highest reality
called the one or tohen a concept that
cannot be understood or described in any
way being hidden in a radical apathetic
Darkness
this one then emanates or flows over
into something called the news often
translated with words like intellect or
mind which is the archetype of all
things in the world and the place of the
platonic forms
news then also emanates into the
so-called Soul or Obsession which in
turn creates the world of nature or our
physical Universe of time and space
the neoplatonists then conceive of a
return back from the physical up the
ladder of reality back to the Noose and
eventually to the one so everything
flows from the one and returns to the
one and the goal of the human being is
to turn away from physicality and the
material traveling Inward and
contemplating his true noetic reality
thus returning to her home in the news
and they're experiencing a mystical
Unity with that noose and even maybe
ultimately with the one itself
there is a lot more to these ideas of
course and I highly again suggest you go
watch my previous episode which covers
the thought of neoplatanism more
generally but for sure these ideas in
their different forms and different
interpretations have been massively
influential on the abrahamic religions
influencing their Theology and the
category they're often called mysticism
in general and Islam is no different
when we look at the intellectual history
of Islam from the falsafar tradition of
IBN Cena and others to the Kalam
theologians and Sufi Mystics aspects of
neoplatonism can be found everywhere
this is truly a fascinating topic but
also a complicated and very vast one
there is so much to explore when it
comes to neoplatonism in Islamic thought
that there is no way of doing it justice
in a single episode unless we want to be
here all week so our goal today is to
give a more General overview of this
landscape touching on some examples and
trying to understand the way that these
Muslim thinkers conceived of the
relationship between these two
Traditions so where does this story
begin well basically at the very
beginning
in the earliest years of the Islamic
religion and its civilization Muslims
had access to these ideas during the
heights of the Abbasid caliphate in the
9th to 10th century and during the
so-called translation movement texts
from all around the world were
translated into Arabic and studied by
the Muslim and non-muslim philosophers
and theologians many of these translated
texts were obviously Greek and the
ancient Greek philosophers like Plato
and Aristotle had a high standing and
reputation in this context
there was a general attitude that any
knowledge or wisdom was good as long as
it didn't contradict Islamic teachings
and a common opinion was that these old
philosophers basically believed and
taught the same thing as Islam albeit
imperfectly
so when we read the early Islamic
philosophers like al-kindi al-farabi and
ibncena we see them argue that these
same truths can be found in philosophy
as in the Quran only expressed in
different languages both in symbolic
terms and and literally a few of these
translated texts became especially
influential on the trajectory of the
Islamic intellectual tradition in
particular there was a text called the
Theology of Aristotle the uthulhijia
aristatales which became perhaps the
most widespread and popular source for
philosophical teachings as the name
suggests the text was thought to have
been written by Aristotle who for much
of the medieval period was seen as the
philosopher par excellence
indeed he was often simply called the
philosopher
but Plato and others were also seen as
important of course and in fact the
Muslim thinkers did not believe that
there was any major discrepancy or
difference between the teachings of
Plato and Aristotle but that they
represented a single tradition of
philosophical truth so when these texts
like the Theology of Aristotle appear to
have ideas that we would recognize as
significantly more platonist in nature
that wasn't strange at all for them but
in fact as it would become clear much
later the Theology of Aristotle was not
a work by Aristotle at all instead it is
an Arabic translation or in kind of a
paraphrasing semi-copy of the any ads by
platinus the figure is often seen as the
founder of neoplatonism in particular it
was a translation or paraphrase of any
ads four through six so while the Muslim
thinkers thought that they were reading
the ideas of Aristotle and they would
indeed adopt actual Aristotelian
teachings in terms of logic and natural
science through other actually authentic
Works they were actually reading and
adapting ideas from neoplatonism and
this becomes a decisive thing for the
whole history of Islamic thought which
became infused with neoplatonic
influence just to drive this point home
even more another key text in this early
context was another semi-translation
called
discourse on the pure good known later
in Latin translation as the Liber of the
causes this text was also attributed to
Aristotle for much of the ages but as it
turns out it was actually a modified
translation of the elements of theology
by proclus another Central neoplatonic
thinker so as you can see the Islamic
scholars were introduced to key
neoplatonic ideas and texts even if they
didn't realize it themselves but after
all this is all just semantics in the
end because regardless if this was
neoplatonic or Aristotelian ideas the
Islamic scholars saw in these ideas a
kindred tradition to that of Islam that
the same truths were expressed in these
texts as in the Quran only in a
different way and as we'll see soon you
can kind of see why so now we have a
general understanding that Muslim
Scholars of various kinds were
introduced to near platonic ideas
through these different translated texts
and that there was often although not
always of course a general
open attitude towards these ideas that
were often seen as being in harmony with
Islam and that they could actually
complement that religion so how does
this show itself or how does this
manifest itself across history in
Islamic thought of various kinds well
like I said the Islamic thinkers saw in
the Quran many indications that it was
expressing the same truth as that of
philosophy
in verses like quote surely we belong to
God and to him we return and quote as he
originated you so you will return
the meaning of these verses of
everything originating from God and
eventually returning back to God sounds
very neoplatonic don't they everything
originates from the one and returns to
the one this is one of the core
characteristics of the philosophy
furthermore the concept of the one and
the strictly Transcendent monotheistic
god of Islam seems to basically be
pointing to the same thing indeed one of
the names of God and Islam is literally
al-wahed the one in any case the Islamic
thinkers saw these similarities and ran
with them this was clearly the same
truth expressed in two different ways
and we find this in different schools
and movements in Islamic history
the least surprising place to find
neoplatonic influence is perhaps in the
falsafa tradition that group of
philosophers that very openly were
reading and building on ideas of their
Greek predecessors in other words
thinkers like al-kindi al-farabi and
ebencina adopted the ideas and language
of new platonism to a major degree in
their philosophical exposition of the
Islamic religion and Beyond
while platinus himself oscillated
between using the word God to refer to
the news sometimes and the Run other
times the Islamic thinkers would
basically exclusively identify God Allah
with the concept of the one the utterly
Transcendent Simplicity Beyond
description and understanding which
originates all other realities this
originating or creation especially in
thinkers like al-farabi and the bencina
often take the form of emanation as a
key feature the one or God emanates or
flows over into that which is other than
him in other words creation
god is perfect and that Perfection
necessitates that he creates the
universe through an overflow and
emanation from his eternal light they
also then theorized that the first thing
that God creates is the first intellect
followed by a bunch of other intellects
often identified with the planetary
spheres of ptolemaic astronomy so as you
can tell here we have some of the most
basic characteristics of neoplatonism
used to complement and explain Islam's
conception of God creating the world to
dive a little deeper into this let's
look at one particular figure probably
the most famous influential and
significant philosopher in Islamic
history IBN Cena also known under his
Latin name avicenna in most of his
philosophical work including the massive
ashifa the healing the fascinating
remarks and admonitions and even short
treatises like the resellers the
Treatise on love he shows his clear debt
to neoplatonic language and metaphysics
famously it been seen at the find God as
the necessary being or necessary
existence
the only existent in reality that is
necessary the only being that has to be
by its very nature and whose Essence is
existence itself he has a whole famous
argument for the existence of God in
which he comes to this conclusion which
we should probably discuss properly in a
separate episode in any case God is
necessary in himself and the causal
Factor behind all other existence who
are contingent rather than necessary
they exist but they might as well not
exist so they they don't have to exist
but they always have a cause so to say
in any case we find similarities in have
been seen as God or necessary being both
with the neoplatonic one but also with
Aristotle's prime mover
he along with his colleagues didn't just
copy the ideas of the Greeks as many
have wrongly claimed as I hope you will
see the Islamic thinkers built and
developed those ideas further in
fascinating ways partly as a result of
the fact that they based their
interpretations on the Quran and Islamic
you know the basic teachings of Islam so
many people often claim that well the
Muslim thinkers they simply copied the
Greeks this is not true the Muslim
thinkers were very original they took of
course huge inspiration from many of the
Greek philosophers but they built upon
those and innovated on those ideas to a
major degree which again I hope you'll
see in some of these thinkers that we'll
be talking about today for example it
been seen as necessary being is in many
ways similar to the platinian one but in
other ways it differs while patanus
would say that the one is beyond things
like being or existence and knowledge
have been seen as God is that reality
which has those attributes per
definition he writes in a word called
the idanesh namah report it has become
evident therefore that there is a
primary entity in the world which is not
in the world though the being of the
world comes from it its existence which
is necessary is due to itself
in reality it is absolute existence all
things exist due to it in the same
manner as the light of the sun is due to
itself whereas the illumination all
other things receive from the Sun is
accidental
this analogy would have been correct if
the sun were the basis of its own
illumination this is not the case
because the illumination of the sun has
a subject whereas the being of the
necessary existence has not subject but
stands by itself
God has existence he isn't Beyond
existence but absolute existence itself
which all other existence derives now
you could argue that this is just a
semantic difference and that platanus
meant a similar thing when he said that
the one is beyond existence but the
difference is definitely there on the
page at least and as we go down the
chain of being we see that he like we
said before adopts the idea of emanation
from the first principle or necessary
existence through the mediation of
intellect through the material world as
well as the possibility of an Ascent or
return back up that ladder according to
bencina from one there can only appear
one and so the first thing that
originates or emanates from God is the
numerically singular first intellect
which is called in Arabic the aqual the
intellect or literally the owl the first
intellect now this of course very
similar to the position of the news and
translated as intellect in platinus as
well unlike God himself this one
intellect has a kind of Multiplicity in
it though as it contemplates both itself
and its source God
so this leads to the fact that it
creates another second intellect as well
as the body and the form of a celestial
sphere
in ibncena system there follows nine
intellects in the descending order from
the first intellect all associated with
a particular planetary sphere and
sometimes also identified with the
angels of religious language
at the bottom we reach the 10th
intellect also called the active
intellect which rules over and emanates
the sublunary material world that we
live in
now keep in mind that to ibncena all of
this is controlled by God it is not that
these intellects have creative powers in
themselves per se the active intellect
doesn't create the material world God
creates the material world but he
creates the material world through the
active intellect so we have a pretty
platonic or plutinian system here one
that however expands the simple idea of
the one intellect Concept in platinus to
instead include 10 separate intellects
we also mentioned that ebencina includes
the idea of the ascent or return which
is so important in neoplatonism indeed
even though ibencina is seen as a
peripatetic rational philosopher who
figures in a strictly logical
philosophical tradition he also has a
pretty strong mystical side to him
was Eben Cena and Mystic and there's
debate over this but we can certainly
confirm that his writings include some
definitely mystical ideas the last part
of his Masterpiece called isharatan
bihat was dedicated to mysticism or
Sufism and works like the Persian Danish
Nama the Treatise of love and the
commentary on
not to be confused with the novel of the
same name by even to fail describe a
kind of mystical descent back from the
material to the higher realities in some
places he even speaks of the possibility
of the self uniting with the necessary
being in any case IBN Cena or avicenna
is obviously one of the most if not the
most significant philosopher in the
history of the Islamic world and its
influence was immense
both in Scholastic Christendom in Europe
but also in his native region and
religion
even the Kalam theologians were
influenced by him and his ideas although
they often criticized and rejected many
of these particular ideas some aspects
have still made their way into
mainstream Kalam theology as well both
in Sunni and Shia Islam and in Shi Islam
we in fact have one of the most clearest
manifestations of neoplatonist
philosophy in all of the Islamic World
indeed the ismailis who are the second
largest branch of shi Islam basically
adopted neoplatonism as the core of
their entire theology from the earliest
periods until this very day
while they of course added their own
flavor to it the ismailis are possibly
the Muslim group that adopted the system
of platinus to the fullest extent and
connected it in unique ways to Islamic
concepts of Prophecy and Revelation
eschatology creation Etc their idea of
God is also identified with the one and
then a similarly apathetic way God is
beyond all being and descriptive concept
whatsoever this is followed by the
intellect or the uncle which is the
source of Revelation and the Quran the
intellect is the umal kitab or mother of
the book mentioned in the Quran and it
is the light which the prophet Muhammad
received and translated into human
language as the Quran this is similarly
followed by the Universal Soul the
nefsel kulia in Arabic and then the
world of nature
when we read the greatest Smiley
theologians and Scholars there is no
denying the fundamentally near platonist
basis of their entire system
thinkers like Abu yakubal sejastani
followed platinus relatively closely
while hamidadin al-kirmani expanded the
vision of reality into further
complexity ismailism has already gotten
a dedicated episode which you can go
back and watch if you want to know more
particularly about their fascinating
neoplatonic Theology and the ways that
they Implement that into their
perspectives and and ideas on the
Islamic religion but it is a very
significant and important piece of the
puzzle here it's really interesting to
see how core Islamic and quranic
concepts are equated often very
elegantly with neoplatonic themes
for example in the jamiel hechmatane of
the ismaili philosopher and poet Nasir
khusro he describes eschatological
themes of the Resurrection Gathering
paradise and hell in allegorical
Teutonic ways quote if it is asked what
is Paradise we replied that it is a
world of spirits and a mind of delights
and if it is asked what is hell we say
that it is a mind of agonies and
torments
if it is asked what the Gathering is on
the day of judgment we reply that it is
the Assembly of particular souls in the
presence of the universe also
a key part in the chain of neoplatonic
influence on Islamic thought is the
anonymous and mysterious group known as
the ichwan as Safar or the Brethren of
Purity who is known to us through their
50 Epistles
in it they tackle themes of philosophy
and Islam through esoteric ways and with
strong neoplatonic leanings while they
were Anonymous most Scholars today are
fairly certain in identifying the
Brethren as a group of ismailis in
particular which makes sense based on
what we have just said
but their Epistles nonetheless would be
very influential on later developments
both in XI and Sunni Islam we already
talked about the mystical tendencies
that have been Cena and mysticism is
indeed perhaps the most fruitful part of
this whole discussion now as we know the
word mysticism is incredibly flawed in
many ways but I think we all kind of
know what we mean when we use that term
and in Sufism which is often called
Islamic mysticism we find a lot of
parallels with neoplatonism and this is
for good reason as we saw in the
dedicated episode on neoplatonism
platinus is often considered a kind of
Mystic himself
an important part of his philosophy was
the idea of the ascent of the soul the
idea that because everything comes or
emanates from the one it all also
returns back to it the cell for some
aspect of the self is always in the
noetic world it is in the news or the
intellect and there is a possibility and
even encouragement to turn away from
this lower material world and return
inward to Journey inside oneself and
soul to go to its deepest depths where
it is one with the nose and thus
experience what is called a mystical
Union with the news thetanus even seems
to think that it is possible to shed all
forms of individuality and separateness
and thus be mystically United with the
one itself if you know your mysticism
these are obviously some of the most
recurring and important themes in that
Hall
tradition or that you know the whole
category of mysticism and platinus and
neoplatonism is a key point and a key
influence on that whole vocabulary and
the whole symbolism and all these
descriptions and and ways of describing
the mystical experience and obviously in
Sufism or Islamic mysticism in general
we find it as well and all over the
place
from the earliest sufis Like a Villain
Junaid dharani and the school in Baghdad
we see an emphasis on the mystical
Journey or path
that the devoted Muslim Mystic should
purify himself through renunciant
practices asceticism prayers and
devotion so that his soul can become
refined eventually shed its attachment
to the material world entirely and even
reached the state of fanaa or
annihilation in God when the Mystic
loses all sense of separate existence
becomes extinguished and Only God
himself is witnessed as the truly real
like the only reality
it is this experience similar in many
ways to the union with the one described
by platinus that is expressed in
ecstatic utterances like halaja's famous
anal haq I am the truth
and at the same time in this early
period we see similar but unique
mystical developments in the Islamic
West in al-andalus
here the charismatic Mystic slash
philosopher IBN masara develops a former
philosophical Islamic mysticism strongly
near platonist in nature where there is
a focus on the concept of ET de Bar
contemplation and ibra literally
crossing over from the sensible world to
the world Beyond
a process of ascent which starts by
contemplating nature itself and its
beauty which are the signs of God then
ascending to the higher Realms through
gradual levels of contemplation until
one reaches the top of the ladder the
followers of IBN Masada which came to be
known as the al-mu attabirun the
contemplators became quite influential
in Al andalus and the Maghrib and would
become a major influence on the
philosophical Sufism of figures like IBN
Arabi and IBN sabayin because these
neoplatonic adjacent ideas are indeed
present throughout Sufism broadly
defined not just these spiritual Ascent
that we have mentioned but also the idea
that the created world is a kind of
image or mirror of the Divine archetype
something similar to the platonic world
of forms and this is not just in the
sometimes more controversial thinkers
like IBN Arabi who will dedicate a lot
of time to later but some of these
themes can also be found in some of the
most mainstream and widely accepted
Islamic authorities in history such as
for example in his mishkatel Anwar the
niche of Lights which is essentially a
commentary on the light verse in the
Quran gazali seems to present ideas that
are rather neoplatonist in nature such
as for example a process of emanation
and reality using the symbolism of light
from the Quran gazali writes in the
mishkat that there is a hierarchy of
light from the lowest to the highest
that the human you know Sufi as he was
the human being can climb up this sort
of hierarchy on the journey back to God
and God is seen as the first light he
also writes that these lights flow out
from each other and in the end he states
that there is actually just one light
which is God and this is all very
neoplatonic furthermore in the same book
in the mushrattle Anwar he also seems
very strongly to indicate that
everything in this physical world is a
kind of copy or mirror of the spiritual
World which reminds us a lot of course
of the world of forms and the News
Doctrine in neop mechanism
he writes quote even though there are
two worlds spiritual and physical
sensible and intelligible Etc the Divine
Mercy provides a correspondence between
the two Realms in such a way that there
is not a single entity in this world
which is not a symbol of the other world
but one of the most interesting and
significant figures in this context is
of course the sheikhil Akbar the
greatest Master IBN Arabi perhaps the
greatest expounder of sufi-oriented
metaphysics in history his school of
thought which is often known under the
name akbari or akbariya contains some
really strong new platonic themes
whether or not that was intentional on
his part or not indeed he has even
sometimes been called IBN aflatoon the
son of Plato because it is sometimes
really strong platonic features of his
system now it's important to once again
stress the fact that these thinkers
themselves simply saw themselves as
explicating Islam and nothing else if
the pre-islamic Hellenic philosophers
said things that correspond to their own
ideas that is simply because of the fact
that truth is truth and truth is not
exclusive to Islam even if it is the
truth to the fullest extent
earlier philosophers and Mystics also
had access to truth sometimes even
earlier Divine Revelations which
explains why the ideas of someone like
platinus are so similar to their
understanding of the Quran and of Islam
in general
according to them this was a long
mystical tradition that stretched back
to figures like Aristotle Plato and all
the way back to the first man Adam but
which was perfected in the Islamic
tradition and even though IBN Arabi
wasn't really a big fan of falsafar
philosophy as such he does recognize
that there is truth there he even refers
to Plato himself as a flatoon ilahi the
Divine Plato in the futohatel Makia
furthermore in the preface to that
massive magnum opus the futohatan Makia
the meccan revelations even Arabi makes
clear the truth is always truth
regardless of who says it we shouldn't
disregard everything a person says just
because he is an unbeliever or that he
has faulty opinions in some respects
because some of what that person says
can still be true and Truth is always
good
quote as for your statement the
philosopher has no religion the fact
that he has no religion does not prove
that everything he says is false this
ability to assess truth and falsehood is
a perception by means of Reason using
the primary rational faculty which every
intelligent person has
later he says quote so when there comes
some matter that the intellect deems
possible and the lawgiver is silent
about it is inappropriate for us to
reject it outright we may choose whether
or not to accept it furthermore we must
not forget the mystical and experiential
side of things not only did these
thinkers see a correspondence between
quranic Islamic teachings and for
example neoplatonism but their mystical
experiences confirmed as much too when
someone like IBN Arabi writes he does so
based on mystical unveiling and
illumination
experiences of the truth itself
experiences of the real or reality as it
is
these experiences not only confirm the
truth of the Islamic religion to them
but also corresponded to ideas in
neoplatonism when titanus describes not
only Union with the one but also the
general structure of reality as
emanating from the one and consisting of
a kind of unified whole in some way as
well as the mirroring of the spiritual
and mundane world this seemed to be the
same thing as what they themselves
experienced while in heightened mystical
state so if we want to believe their
claims of mystical experience this is an
important piece of authenticating
evidence and even still when we read IBN
Arabi and find what are arguably
neoplatonic themes he usually doesn't
use the philosophical terms he does talk
about the intellect every now and then
but more usually he will use quranic
terms such as the pen the Kalam and only
sometimes sort of allude to the
philosophical concept saying oh by the
way this is synonymous with the
intellect or whatever
this will be clear soon but it confirms
what we have been saying even Arabi and
his followers as well as those like them
saw themselves as simply explicating and
exploring the depths and the truths of
the Islamic religion of the Quran and
the Sunnah of the Prophet Muhammad and
if there is a correspondence there with
ideas in other schools like neoplatonism
that is a mere assault of the
universality of truth and not that they
have been quote unquote influenced by
that school and then apply it to their
religion whether we want to share their
view of the situation or believe them so
to say is of course up to us but it is
an important perspective to keep in mind
so the teachings of IBN Arabi are
incredibly complex and deep and there is
no way we can do it justice here but
according to this Mystic all of the
cosmos is seen as the self-disclosure or
manifestation of God to be more specific
it is the manifestation of the
attributes of God he likes to employ a
famous Hadith kudzi where God says quote
I was a hidden treasure and I loved to
be known so I created the world so that
I might be known
the hidden treasure referred to here is
God's own reality his qualities and
attributes which he loves or wishes to
see manifested to be experienced in a
mode other than his eternal
self-knowledge of himself to IBN Arabi
God in his absolute form God in himself
so to say is referred to as the essence
avat in Arabic the essence cannot be
described or understood in any way it is
utterly impossible to experience God's
Essence it is utterly Transcendent of
all qualifications or delimitation we
can only say that it is if even that but
not much else this essence of God and
the name al-haqor the real slash the
truth is often used by banana but to
refer to it is beyond all Concepts even
Concepts like Unity or Oneness itself
but at the same time it somehow contains
unlimited possibility or should I say
actuality
pretty similar to the platinian one
isn't it
but God also has a relationship with
that which is other than him that is the
world of creation and when we talk about
God in relation to Creation we refer to
him with various attributes and
qualities which are also expressed
through his names God in fact has an
infinite number of attributes his
reality is completely unlimited after
all so this aspect of God as a reality
in relation to the world is sometimes
referred to as the level
or the Divinity
but these attributes names and qualities
are only actualized as relationships to
the world because as we saw the actual
essence of God is completely Beyond any
such descriptions
the essence contains these unlimited
attributes somehow even though we can't
attribute anything to it they are as we
saw the hidden treasure talked about in
the Hadith but they don't exist there as
separate realities or parts of the
essence as such they cannot be
conceptualized as different from the
utterly simple Essence but as we also
saw in the Hadith God wants or even
loves to see his treasure manifested
actualized as something to be
experienced so he creates the world for
this reason to be a place of
manifestation for the attributes in his
essence
but in order for this unfathomable
Essence to become something more
concrete it needs to delimit itself
somehow
and indeed because God is utterly
non-deliminable not even
non-delimitation can limit him in other
words because there is no limit to what
God can do he is also able to limit
himself in some way because if he
couldn't limit himself then that would
of course be a limitation on him so
while the essence itself always remains
utterly perfect and unchanged the Divine
reality somehow delimits itself in
stages in the process of creating the
world
he becomes conditioned or entified in a
process of identification
the first step in this process is often
referred to as the most holy effusion
or the first antification
which results in something often called
the al-ahadiya the Unicity this is still
God but God as he sort of looks at
himself here the attributes of God
become a thing that can be recognized
but still as part of an essential Unity
this Most Holy effusion or emanation
known as the neoplatonic language here
is still taking place in God in a way so
to say and Beyond time and space it is
God as he knows his own infinite
attributes and qualities as well as
coming to know the infinite ways that
these attributes can become manifested
in particular forms we often see IBN
Arabi refer to this reality as the
reality of realities the
or the universal reality sometimes also
the muhammadan reality
it is the realm in which all things take
place a kind of place that is neither
God nor the cosmos but also kind of both
God and the cosmos at the same time
it is the archetype of all reality the
place where God has knowledge of all
things all of his own attributes and all
of the ways that those attributes can be
manifested as actual particular things
but it's also a kind of term for the
totality of everything that is other
than God God that is God as the essence
but in an unmanifested way although from
a certain perspective there is nothing
other than God in other words it's kind
of a logos principle about this topic
The Scholar William chiddick writes
quote drawing from terminology he uses
elsewhere his followers call this
reality in God the most holy effusion
and they Define it as God's
self-disclosure to himself in himself or
the self-knowledge by which he knows
every concomitant of his own Infinity
they contrasted with the Holy effusion
and
the creative act that brings all
realities and entities into
manifestation this reality of reality
slash Mohammed in reality the unmanifest
aspect of all these entities in God's
knowledge appears rather similar to the
news or intellect of neoplatonism
it has a lot of the same characteristics
and seem to have a similar role to play
but this statement also becomes
difficult and problematic as we will see
soon I've personally always had trouble
grasping this particular aspect of IBN
arabic's thought it's really difficult
and confusing and to be honest to
actually understand all of this on a
rational level probably isn't even
possible according to IBN Arabi himself
what we need to know is that God knows
himself his attributes and their
possibilities of manifestation and the
world is created to actualize that
purpose
so through his merciful breath the
breath of the old merciful he creates
the cosmos this is the holy effusion
his being is given a place of
manifestation God creates the world
through his merciful breath and thus the
Ayana fabita the immutable entities
those
ways those infinite ways that God's
infinite attributes can become
manifested as particular things come
into being right they are given
existence of their lent existence from
God and thus they exist but in ibnabis
thought it is also a very central theme
that just as everything is Created from
God and everything comes into being it
also constantly returns back to God so
here is that classic neoplatonic
doctrine of the inflow and outflow or
rather the outflow and the inflow right
that everything comes from the one and
returns to the one in IBN Arab is
thought this is represented by the
breath of the all-merciful god breathes
the world into existence and at every
single instant at every moment the world
has created Anew so
existence as we look around in the world
it is a constant flow of things coming
into being and then disappearing and
coming back into being at every instant
which is represented by this breathing
this breathing out and breathing in of
God's breath which creates and returns
in which the world is created and
returns to back at every moment it's
really beautiful symbolism
and what is the first thing that God
creates the first step in the
origination or emanation of the cosmos
the first intellect alcohol
so here we see the triumphant appearance
of the intellect or noose again in
classic neoplatonic fashion but IBN
Arabi also seems to have extended part
of the classic news Doctrine to his idea
of the reality of realities
in any case the first intellect has the
role that it usually has in these kinds
of schemes IBN Arabi himself describes
it as quote the bearer of everything
that is known high and low which takes
from God without intermediary
it is the place where all the knowledge
of things that will be is collected and
stored it is still Beyond time and space
and so it contains all of God's
knowledge and the different ways that
God manifests himself in a unified way
so to say quote the first student that
accepted knowledge through learning not
Essence was the first intellect
he came to understand from God what he
taught it he commanded it to write what
he taught it in the preserved tablet the
Universal Soul that he created from it
so he named it a pen God replied to it
write what has been or what I have
taught and what will be or what I will
dictate to you which is my knowledge
concerning my creation until the day of
Resurrection nothing else
the intellect has a central role to play
in reality it is sometimes equated with
the concept of the Holy Spirit and with
the Nur muhammadiya the light of
Muhammad which is the inspiration for
all prophecy indeed aside from being the
place where all of realities contain so
to say it also has a strong connection
with revelation
in the thought of IBN Arabi there are
three modes of Revelation where the
entirety of God's attributes are
mirrored
one is the Quran of nature that the
cosmos as a whole is a sacred scripture
and the place of God's self-disclosure
the second is the human being the
microcosm to the universal macrocosm
that also reflects all of God's
qualities and then thirdly there is of
course the actual Quran in terms of the
scripture recited by the prophet
Muhammad indeed in the compendium of
Sufi terminology by Abdul razak
al-kashani a famous 14th century thinker
from IBN Arabi School the first
intellect or pen is synonymous with the
quranic concept of um the mother of the
book a kind of archetype for all sacred
scripture including the Arabic Quran
whatever the case this first intellect
then emanates the second Creation The
Universal Soul mafs El culia
this Soul has one phase turned towards
the intellect and God and one towards
creation quote
so the first Mentor in the cosmos is the
first intellect
the first learner who takes from a
created Mentor is the preserved tablet
that is the universal soul this nomic
literature is shariaite that is
According to Islamic law
for the rational thinkers the name of
the preserved tablet is the universal
soul it is the first raised up existent
thing that is acted upon by the
intellect
in relation to the intellect it is like
Eve in relation to Adam it was created
from it and it was coupled with it thus
it became two just as her existence
became too through the newly arrived
thing and knowledge became two through
the newly arrived pen the soul then
emanates the World of Nature and the
sensible universe as we know it come to
be after this point and sort of below
Soul so to say now as we said earlier in
this discussion while there is no doubt
that IBN Arabi employs these very
neoplatonic themes he doesn't
necessarily like to use the
philosophical terms as such at least not
as much
and he doesn't even consider himself to
be doing philosophy or to take these
ideas from the platonism at all
indeed in terms of the intellect being
the first aspect of creation he doesn't
have to look further than the hadiths
themselves in fact there is another
famous Hadith that IBN alabi likes to
refer to where Muhammad is thought to
have said quote the first thing that God
created was the intellect or in another
version he says quote the first thing
that God created was the pen which
tribunal abuse of course synonymous with
the intellect and indeed rather than
using the philosophical terms IBN Arabi
prefers to use these quranic ones as we
have seen in the quotes the intellect is
called the pen al-qalam and the soul is
called the tablet aloha
the pen contains the knowledge of all
things and writes upon the tablet which
thus receives that knowledge and
actualizes it in some way aside from
quranic terms you will sometimes also
use metaphorical language
for example the intellect is often
represented by the eagle and the Soul by
the dove or the ring dove nowhere is
this as explicit as in a relatively
early and short Treatise called
Cosmic unification in the presence of
the eyewitnessing through the Assembly
of the human tree and the four spiritual
Birds we refer to it simply as the
itihadal county or the the Treatise on
unification from here on out in this
work even Arabi describes a mystical
experience where he has plunged into the
depths of his own reality which turns
out of course to be God's reality and
their experience is a vision of a
universal tree and four birds that are
sitting in this tree each of these
characters the tree and the birds
present itself to the Mystic and even
has their own poem to go along with it
to summarize very briefly it turns out
that the tree represents the universal
or perfect man the insanal camel the
accomplished person who perfectly
reflects the reality of realities that
is the totality of all God's names and
attributes in a single form we might
assume that it is in some way himself
that have been out of the experiences
here
in any case this tree also has four
birds all of whom represent important
aspects of that reality the reality of
the perfect man which is synonymous with
in a way with reality itself because
he's a reflection of the structure of
reality and of the Divine the Divine
world the ring Dove represents the
tablet the Universal Soul the Royal
Eagle represents the pen or the first
intellect the Anka or Phoenix represents
Prime matter another philosophical
concept that should not be confused with
matter as we know it but a kind of
higher matter from which even imaginal
and spiritual forms are made and lastly
the fourth bird is the black crow which
represents something called the
universal body which we could consider
the the the the physical world as a
whole in a sense this is the crow that
represents the sort of lowest aspect of
reality which in this text turns out to
not be very low at all if not actually
sort of praises the physical world in a
sort of anti not not outrightly
anti-agnostic but I kind of the opposite
of the Gnostic argument of saying that
the people who who discard the physical
and the material world as evil or dirty
or ugly are completely mistaken there is
a nobility and Beauty to the to the
created world and the physical world as
well as it is a reflection of of God and
of God's attributes so in this
particular Treatise we have a pretty
straightforward exposition of key
neoplatonic ideas but expressed through
quranic and Islamic language but like I
said we find these ideas all over his
writings and the writings of his
followers of the akbari school to this
very day from the concept of the essence
of God being very similar to the
platinian one to the ideas of emanation
or effusion to the news or intellect
concept which while confusing can be
found in both the teachings of the
reality of realities as well as the
Divine pen and even of course the next
stage of the emanation which is the
universal soul or tablet this is all
very neatly within a very
characteristically neoplatonic kind of
scheme being a Mystic IBN Arabi also of
course emphasized the return back a
renouncing of worldliness and turning
inward to our true reality
ultimately we can become annihilated to
reach the state of fanaa and become
United with God becoming one with the
one alone with the alone
just like platinus IBN Arabi teaches us
that God is always present to us and
that it isn't a question of returning to
God or even actually uniting with him
but in a way just realizing that God was
our very being and reality to begin with
the world including ourselves are simply
the ever-changing and fluctuating
self-manifestation of God's being and
attributes the Eternal unfolding of
possibilities inherent in infinite
actuality itself
whether this is the result of direct or
indirect influence or rather question of
two expressions of the same truth based
on mystical experience and unveiling is
hard to say but it's without doubt true
that ideas of a neoplatonic character
can be found in the the key teachings of
the school of IBN Arabi and really all
of Sufism and to some degree all of
Islamic thought in general or I should
say most of Islamic thought of course it
should be remembered that ibnada behind
the school while of course very
influential and important do not
represent all of Sufism or even the
majority of Sufism but he has been and
still is an important piece of that
puzzle and we can see from this and from
our general discussion that neoplatonic
ideas can be found in various places all
over Islamic thought from philosophy to
Kalam theology to Sufi metaphysics even
today there are many in the Muslim
Community who try to maintain and revive
the school or in philosophy of
neapolitanism as a very strong component
of the Islamic religion and its and its
theology basically people who belong to
the akbari school the school of IBN
Arabi of course who still have many
followers around the world to Modern
Scholars like khalilandani who I've
worked with on this channel in the past
who has written many articles arguing
for the value of neoplatonism in Islamic
theology as a very important
tool for for for doing Islamic theology
but also for the World At Large as a
kind of very usable philosophical system
so as you can see some of those core
ideas associated with neoplatonism can
be found all over the intellectual
tradition of Islam in different ways
from the apathetic nature of the one the
idea that the core of reality the source
of all things is this apathetic nature
that cannot be described or understood
in any way that is completely
Transcendent of everything in terms of
the world of Multiplicity or anything we
can imagine or conceive of that is one
of the core features of a lot of Islamic
thinking about God even in the Quran we
see
similar Tendencies of this incredibly
Transcendent monotheistic God but also
in a lot of the Islamic thinkers from
IBN Cena to the sufis of course a lot of
the theological schools had these ideas
even though they do affirm that God has
certain attributes as mentioned in the
Quran that has always been a kind of
debate within Islamic theology how do we
reconcile this idea of the Divine
attributes with the other idea of God's
complete Transcendence and
dissimilar Clarity from All Things some
Islamic scholars chose to follow the
neoplatonic system more closely and have
a more extremely apathetic conception of
God such as the ismailis for example who
adapted the neoplatonic model to to a
much larger degree than perhaps most
Muslim Scholars but also people like IBN
Arabi who conceives of the absolute
nature of God as this concept of the
essence of art which is completely
Beyond any description or understanding
secondly another key near platonic idea
is this idea of emanation that the one
or reality the different hypotheses or
levels of reality emanate from one
another the one emanates the intellect
which emanates the soul which emanates
the world and in a lot of Islamic
thinking and philosophy we also see the
very same idea from people like IBN Cena
same with people like al-farabi who also
conceives of this emanation of various
different intellects to many of the
sufis who would also conceal reality in
many similar ways Surah vardadi and his
illuminationism has these different
lights that emanate from the the noodle
Anwar the the light of Lights even it
talks about lights that emanate from or
flow out from each other and of course
as we saw IBN Arabi has an incredibly
new platonic system where even God
becomes antified or becomes somehow
somehow emanates into these different uh
levels in which the being of God can can
sort of manifest himself it's all over
the place in that sense and lastly in
neoplatonism there's this idea of
climbing back up this ladder of reality
from the mundane world to leave the
physical behind and travel inward to
find our true spiritual home or our true
reality and somehow even become United
with the Divine this idea of Union
mystica which is so common to
neoplatonic thinking in general this we
also find of course all over the Islamic
intellectual tradition even in the
rational philosophers like IBN Cena he
also conceives of the sort of highest
achievement as this Union with the
necessary being becoming United somehow
with God however that is interpreted
that language in that symbolism is is
key to many of these philosophers even
IBN rush to veruis who is very
anti-neoplatonic in that way he also
conceives of this idea of of United with
the active intellect and these themes
are of course perhaps mostly visible in
the tradition of Sufism or Islamic
mysticism often so-called where there is
this emphasis on traveling on the
spiritual path on a ascending levels or
stations until one reaches the highest
stations which include for example the
idea of fanaa of becoming an annihilated
in God or becoming completely
extinguished and realizing that God is
the only reality so this is of course
very similar to platinus's idea of
uniting or becoming the one in that
sense it is clear there are many
parallels and correspondences between
the school of neoplatonism and a lot of
Islamic thought which I hope I have
given you proper examples of in this
episode and today we've only looked at a
really tiny selection of of thinkers and
movements within Islam that has these
kind of of
ideas and these kind of neoplatonic
features to it right but
there's the topic is much faster than
that and even then we've only focused on
one of the major abrahamic religions
because indeed neoplatonism has been
influential on all of the so-called
Western religions or abrahamic religions
and even Beyond it's it's one of the
most influential and and important
philosophical movements in schools
systems in all of history that has
influenced everything from Judaism
Kabbalah within Judaism Christianity uh
western esotericism or esotericism
generally all across the board
neoplatanism is incredibly influential
and that is again why it is so
incredible that I am part of this
massive collaboration with some of my
great colleagues here on YouTube uh a
collaboration that is sorely needed in
order for this this very significant
school near platonism to be to be
presented to a broader audience and to
also talk about the different ways that
has influenced our world and the way
that we see things and some of the major
religions and intellectual schools that
are still part of our society and world
today hopefully you've learned a thing
or two here about neoplatanism both in
general but also in particular in this
episode about its relationship with
Islamic thought and Sufism we will of
course be discussing the application
more in the future because it is a topic
that's going to come up whether we like
it or not but now we've laid some of the
groundwork to see how this tradition has
well first of all in our previous
episode what this tradition and
philosophy is to begin with but also now
also how it is influenced some of the
greatest in intellectual and religious
traditions
in history and even today so look
forward to more episodes on this topic
check out the videos by the other
channels thank you as always to all of
my patrons of course to keep this
channel going without whom I would not
be able to do any of this and I will see
you next time
[Music]